vous regardez votre caméra la seule
chose que vous avez à faire Etienne
c'est dire magnétos Serge
magnéto Serge
Étienne Daho
alors Méline est-ce qu'on peut apporter
le porte-voix parce que comme Dao est-ce
quelqu'un qui a pas une voix énorme
ça commence bien
voilà donc Étienne tu sais comment ça
marche voilà si tu as besoin voilà
alors malgré ce succès Étienne Daho vous
êtes toujours très réservé très très
timide comme ça vous allez un peu sûr de
vous
ouais
mais pas tant que ça quand même non
c'est ce qui me ce qui m'impressionne
c'est la télé pour moi c'est comme une
loupe d'ailleurs ça me fait très bizarre
d'être là je regarde l'émission depuis
des années j'étais jamais vue merci pour
l'invitation et
c'est vrai que c'est un endroit où je
suis pas très très à l'aise en fait je
suis un musicien donc mon truc c'est
d'être en studio d'essayer de faire des
bonnes chancelles voilà c'est c'est ça
mon métier après d'aller en parler je
trouve ça va vachement difficile mais je
vais faire mon mieux ce soir
[Applaudissements]
je me disais que c'était peut-être dû
Étienne à une prime enfance assez
chaotique quand même oui sûrement
Capricorne comme moi oui oui c'est vrai
ouais moi je trouve beaucoup d'affinités
avec d'autres capricornes c'est un signe
pas très pas très drôle quoi c'est des
gens qui sont assez laborieux assez
scrupuleux c'est pas très gai mais ça
c'est la vitrine la vitrine qui est un
peu pratique d'ailleurs ça permet d'être
un peu plus tard
c'est qui Pierrot oui
[Applaudissements]
bien donc Capricorne vous êtes né à Oran
en Algérie et pas du tout à Rennes comme
disait vos biographies au départ au
départ vous aviez pas corrigé quoi quand
les bio disait oui je m'en foutais un
peu je pensais pas que ça durait aussi
longtemps mais
depuis alors vous êtes né à Oran votre
père était militaire il était appelé
c'était la guerre d'Algérie votre mère
était chimiste et votre mère jamais été
chimiste
[Applaudissements]
j'ai recommencer elle était quoi
au foyer
comme mon père est parti en fait elle a
trouvé un boulot comme secrétaire dans
une dans une boîte de produits chimiques
mais elle a jamais été chimiste du tout
un lien avec la chimie un peu lointain
quand même c'était pas les mêmes c'est
pas les mêmes salaires et votre mère
était fan d'Elvis
ça j'ai eu la chance d'avoir des parents
très fan de musique donc à la base mon
père je veux de la Tromp tout simple
c'était un fin de musique acheter
beaucoup de disques donc j'ai eu une
base de musique très très tôt à la
maison c'est vrai qu'à l'âge de 3 ans
vous connaissez déjà des chansons par
cœur oui j'avais une mémoire visuelle et
je montrais les disques que je voulais
que je voulais écouter
donc tout commence bien et là votre père
abandonne la famille dans des
circonstances assez c'est bizarre
dites-vous partie chercher des
cigarettes et en fait comme dans la
chanson dans cette même un peu plus un
peu plus épais que ça quoi parce que
c'était en fait ça ressemblait une
trahison une vraie trahison parce que
parce qu'en fait il est il a laissé donc
ses enfants donc mes sœurs et moi et ma
mère en Algérie qui était vraiment en
plein cauchemar quoi c'était vraiment
très dangereux à ce moment-là et lui a
demandé le livret de famille pour
pouvoir se barrer quoi en faisant passer
une autre femme pour ça pour sa femme
qui a un truc c'est quand même là c'est
le top niveau de de du rien quoi et de
la trahison et
et donc voilà vous l'avez jamais revu
votre père si je l'ai revu quand j'ai
commencé à chanter
et un jour c'est un truc terrible parce
qu'en fait
il s'est présenté l'Olympia quand ça
commence à marcher pour moi et il s'est
présenté comme étant mon père avec sa
nouvelle famille et
donc on est venu me dire ça juste avant
de monter sur scène pour moi c'était un
concert terrible quoi parce que je
savais qu'il allait peut-être voir ma
mère et tout et c'était pas eu depuis
des années c'était quand même très très
chaud quoi et
j'ai refusé ensuite qu'il vienne me voir
dans dans la loge et c'est un truc que
j'ai toujours regretté enfin j'ai
vraiment culpabilisé
[Applaudissements]
ça va être plus dur
c'est la vie oui oui bien sûr c'est la
vie votre père était assez fortuné mais
évidemment quand il s'en va à votre mère
se retrouve avec trois gosses et sans
argent et puis c'était la guerre quoi
c'était la guerre d'Algérie avec le
climat dans d'anxiété la mort
omniprésente vous dites on pouvait pas
passer devant les fenêtres parce qu'on
avait peur de prendre des balles quoi
il est arrivé de rentrer de l'école et
de trouver vraiment des Macchabées voilà
des mecs avec le la cervelle qui sortait
une vision assez traumatisante et puis
il y a eu plein de choses assez
traumatisantes j'en ai fait une chanson
une chanson qui s'appelle de bien jolie
flamme une chanson que j'ai que j'ai des
dis à ma mère qui était vraiment toute
seule pour nous défend et mais ensuite
bon ça c'est le côté le côté un peu oui
il y avait le sens séché et puis il y
avait aussi les grands-parents parce que
vous viviez chez vos grands-parents qui
avaient une échoppe mi-bar mi-épicerie
au bord de la mer là il y avait un
juke-box et
et voilà et c'est là que Étienne Daho
dans ce jus de box dans cette période
absolument troublée et tragique vous
avez découvert Sylvie Vartan Françoise
Hardy des gens avec qui nous
travaillaient 20 ans plus tard
tous les tubes de l'époque donc c'est
vraiment un truc magique vraiment c'est
pour ça qu'avec le temps je pense que
j'ai une infection toute particulière
pour cette période parce que c'est
vraiment un moment qui est un joli
moment quoi pour moi parce qu'entre
temps c'est vrai que j'étais en pension
à l'âge de 4 ans c'était tout petit et
mon angoisse était de quand j'entrais le
week-end en bus qui est personne
c'était terrible pour moi enfin c'est
une angoisse quoi vraiment donc là ce
coin de ce moment jukebox musique soleil
ça ça c'est un truc vraiment bien c'est
la musique qui vous a sorti de tout ça
parce qu'ensuite vos grandes sœurs vous
font découvrir la motard les groupes
anglais des années 60 les Beatles
etc et puis vous découvrez tout seul
Hendrix les Doors et puis un jour à
l'âge de 15 ans chez un soldeur vous
tombez sur ce disque avec la banane là
ça m'a fait découvrir le rock ce disque
oui puis c'est ça ça a été dire que j'ai
commencé à devenir obsessionnel sur
certains disques c'est à dire je vis la
musique d'une manière obsessionnelle
tiens je peux écouter indice pendant
deux ans et si j'aime un artiste il faut
que j'achète tout que j'ai tous les bio
les DVD ça je enfin c'est vraiment il
faut que je maîtrise le sujet en passant
à un autre c'est c'est un truc
aussi il y a effectivement le Velvet
Underground mais il y a aussi les Pink
Floyd à l'époque de silbaret
et puis aussi beaucoup beaucoup mais ça
c'est aussi des choses de mon enfance
c'est c'est Bryan Wilson les Beach Boys
pour moi c'est vraiment très très liasse
ça cet album surfing Safari pour moi
c'est vraiment c'est toute le c'est
vraiment ça c'est toute la magie de de
l'enfance quoi vous avez trouvé comment
l'album de Brian Wilson qui est sorti je
préfère l'original c'est un peu décevant
le peut-être le plus beau concert jamais
vu voilà et puis ensuite on va pas
raconter toute la vie d'Étienne là où il
devient l'idole des jeunes à son tour
hein ça a été énorme et ça l'est
toujours d'ailleurs c'est c'est
incroyable le réévolution
et alors un jour au milieu de cette
gloire la Lumière que vous voyez depuis
que vous êtes tout petit en fermant les
yeux cette lumière s'éteint
oui
c'est très lié en fait
la disparition la disparition de mon
père a été comme une bombe à retardement
en fait c'est un moment que je travaille
beaucoup je pensais régler un peu mes
problèmes en accumulant les choses en
bossant en travaillant avec ça c'est
vraiment des rustines quoi en plus la
musique étant ma passion vraiment j'ai
beaucoup bossé pour moi ça a très bien
marché c'était génial c'était un cadeau
absolument incroyable mais travailler
avec les autres aussi c'est à dire des
gens que j'ai que dont j'étais fan quand
j'étais adolescent que tout d'un coup
venait me demander de travailler avec
eux ça c'était quand même des mots et
puis un jour c'est vrai que j'ai il y a
eu un truc surmenage enfin voilà la
maison qui était prêt pour les deux ans
qui venaient
en plus comme je suis à fêtard je
dormais 14 secondes par nuit je bossais
beaucoup je travaillais beaucoup et puis
à un moment bon bah voilà
une sensation de gouffre quoi vous avez
le sentiment que le meilleur est
derrière vous
surtout j'ai vraiment choisi ce métier
parce que j'aime la musique et parce que
j'ai envie d'en faire et au bout d'un
moment c'est un métier on est beaucoup
représentation beaucoup plus qu'en
création et ça ça me manque vraiment
donc j'ai essayé de depuis en tout cas
d'essayer de de faire un équilibre entre
la création et puis côté VRP
non mais ce qui est incroyable c'est
qu'à ce moment-là vous avez le sentiment
qu'il faut mourir pour pour renaître
quoi qu'une nouvelle vie doit commencer
et c'est l'époque où commence à courir
la rumeur de votre mort c'est une
coïncidence absolument pas
non mais c'est vrai c'est à ce moment là
qu'on a commencé à dire il est mort il
est mort du sida à l'hôpital de Rennes
et quand vous croisez des gens et vous
disent ah ben tu es là toi je croyais
que tu étais mort mais incroyable si tu
es arrivé à vous et Apple ma carte n'est
ce qui est pas mal remarqué
c'est mieux
non non
vous êtes pas allé à la télé pour dire
regardez je vais bien quoi enfin bon on
aurait déjà mis la fesse et 83 donc
c'était encore plus sensible c'était
vraiment la lèvre moi c'était je sais
pas en 92 13 ça commençait parce que
j'ai fait un album qui s'appelle urgence
enfin j'étais à la base cet album dans
les fonds étaient reversés Institut
Pasteur pour le sida et je pense qu'à ce
moment-là des gens pensaient que j'étais
un peu plus impliqué que ce que je ne
voulais dire et ça a commencé moi je dis
bon c'est la énième connerie sur moi ça
va durer 30 secondes et puis ça va ça va
disparaître et donc à ce moment
j'habitais à Londres j'ai pas vraiment
j'ai pas vraiment fait gaffe ça me
paraissait pas très important je vais
faire un bon disque et voilà ça va durer
quatre secondes et puis ça c'est
vraiment incruster en kysté c'est
vraiment le truc dont je peux plus me
débarrasser c'est à dire que c'était pas
dur au moment où j'étais à Londres
finalement c'est quand je suis rentré
j'avais un 10 sous le bras et que
j'adorais que je trouvais vraiment
j'avais l'impression de m'être cassé le
cul et vraiment d'avoir fait un beau
disque et tout ça et on me parlait de ça
j'ai l'impression qu'on parlait plus
d'un truc qui était pas la réalité que
ce que je venais de faire et ça ça m'a
rendait un peu dingue ouais les gens m'a
dit vous voyez il cherchait sur votre
visage les les stigmates de la maladie
il y avait ceux qui disaient mais tu
vois bien qu'il est malade et puis ceux
qui étaient allés à son enterrement
c'est-à-dire qu'à l'époque on croisait
régulièrement des gens qui étaient allés
à l'enterrement de DAO quoi vraiment
ouais il disait ah bah faudrait savoir
[Rires]
c'était c'était un cauchemar c'est
terrible vous prenez en pleine gueule la
France
dans mes angoisses c'est vrai que que tu
racontais tout à l'heure vraiment
j'ai toujours eu une angoisse de mort
parce que c'est quelque chose qui était
très très présent depuis tout petit quoi
donc voilà ça tapait direct dans dans et
depuis c'est bien depuis j'ai plus peur
depuis depuis c'est fini et puis en même
temps
[Musique]
la psychanalyse vous a aidé aussi
beaucoup non bien sûr heureusement ça
m'a sorti la tête hors de l'eau mais
c'est à dire que c'est un moment où j'ai
pété les plombs et en plus il y a eu ce
truc là c'est quand même j'ai pas besoin
de ça quoi mais
mais ça a été bien ça m'a permis de
d'envisager autre chose et tout ça ça a
un sens c'est pas c'est pas un truc qui
a pas de sens qui m'est arrivé c'est un
vrai un vrai sens ça m'a permis en plus
de vraiment décider de ce que je voulais
faire décider de comment aller être ma
vie ma carrière et et de pas me laisser
diriger par autre chose voilà je fais ce
que j'aime je suis arrivé à un point
où j'aime ce que je fais j'aime ma place
tout ça c'est un sens et je suis très
heureux quoi c'est peut-être maintenant
qu'il faut mourir
[Musique]
Méline ma petite Méline
[Applaudissements]
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
c'est toi quel chat tu connais c'est
vous le chat
puis après
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon alors on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le chat maman
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu